Each year is,
is very interested in
the problem of value.
And the problem of value fundamentally
is not the problem of what is the world
made up or even how
does the world function,
which are more in some sense more
specifically scientific questions.
But how is it that you should
conduct yourself in the world?
How should you act?
And people act towards aims in a sense,
because we're active creatures and
we're moving from one point to another.
We're moving towards things that we want.
And that means that we're guided by our
desires and we're not only guided by
desires insofar as we
have individual desires,
we're guided by the structure
that consists of how those
desires are related to
one another.
So for example,
if you have a room full of people,
say a room full of children,
they're active and they're each
pursuing their individual desires.
But at some point they may choose
to organize themselves into a game.
And if they organize
themselves into a game,
what they're doing,
for all intents and purposes
is producing a little society,
a little micro society.
And within that micro society,
they're deciding what desires will be
currently expressed and how they'll exist
in relationship to one another.
And that means that they can cooperate
without too much conflict and that they
can jointly move towards,
um,
a joint AME without
and,
and gather all the benefits that
might be associated with that.
And that might be the
accomplishment of the Ame,
whatever it is.
But it also might be just the enjoyment
that's to be had in the pursuit of that
activity.
Now people do that
socially because we have to do that in
order to get along with other people
because our designers have to be
melded with those of other people.
But we also do it psychologically.
And those two things exist in a dance
because as I'm interacting with other
people,
the demands of the fact
that we're interacting make,
require each of us to arrange our desires
in a way that's acceptable to everyone
else.
But at the same time,
while we're doing that,
we're also observing the process
by which those desires are ordered.
And then we internalize that process
and use that to order our own desires.
And then so there's a constant
mutually informative dance between
the individual and the group.
And the culmination of
that is the organization of
society and the simultaneous
organization of the psyche.
And it's that process that needs
you is talking in these paragraphs.
Now you might ask yourself,
well,
what's the utility of articulating such
things and conceptualizing them and
understanding them.
And the answer in some ways,
it's straight forward.
If you don't want to run a
foul of the your own desires,
you have to organize them
because some of them are short term and
some of them are medium term and some of
them are long term.
And some of the main meant
this and some of the main that.
And it isn't necessarily the case
that those desires allow for mutual
fulfillment.
So for example,
maybe you're very interested in pursuing
a sexual relationship with someone,
but you're also very interested in having
a family and some stability in your
life.
Or maybe you're interested in pursuing
a sexual relationship with a whole
sequence of people,
but you're also interested in having
a family of stabilizing your life.
It's not obvious that those desires
can exist in the same universe without
producing what you might think about
as a war and some of that might be a
psychological war,
but some of it's also going to be a war
that actually occurs in the existence.
Well,
you're fighting through the contradictory
consequences of wanting to pursue many
people and formulate a stable
relationship with one person.
Well part of the reason that you want
to think about these sorts of things is
because if you think about them and
get your thoughts and your value system
intelligently and coherently
and cogently laid out,
then when you act out that
value system in the world,
you're going to run into less conflict
and less uncertainty and less misery and
you're going to have a higher probability
of getting what it is that you want.
But you're also going to have a higher
probability of getting what you want in a
way that allows you to cooperate with
other people without entering into too
much conflict with them.
And so in some sense the
purpose that you think,
the reason that you think are the purpose
of thinking is so that you can sort
out how you're going to move forward in
the world without having to directly run
headlong into all the obstacles that you
might run into if you were doing such a
thing blindly.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well,
why would you bother reading philosophy?
The philosophy written
by someone who's great.
And the answer to that is,
is that they can help you think these
things through in a manner that you would
not be capable of doing on your own.
You know,
because Nisha,
I mean it's,
it's difficult to estimate how
intelligent needs you wise,
but I suspect he was
perhaps one in a billion,
which would put him far beyond
the 99.99 ninth percentile.
And there's a massive difference between
the ability of people to think as you
move farther and farther out into
the extremes of intelligence.
And when you have the writings of
someone who's one in a billion,
then you can interact with those
writings in a way that enables you,
if you'll put the time into
benefit from the spectacular
fact of that intelligence.